the european union has agreed to cut
back on natural gas at an emergency
meeting in brussels
russia is slashing deliveries moscow
saying it needs to carry out maintenance
work on a key pipeline and that a
complete stoppage is not on the cards
eu officials don't believe either
statement member states reaching a deal
to voluntarily reduce gas consumption by
15 from next month
as europe's energy ministers met in
brussels on tuesday the urgency of the
challenge they faced had become
increasingly obvious
russia's announcement this week that it
would cut supply of natural gas through
its main pipeline to germany to just a
fifth of capacity meant a bad situation
had become even more dire
a collective agreement to reduce gas
consumption has been long needed but
brussels initial demand for a mandatory
15 cut had caused uproar last week as a
result the text agreed by the member
states has multiple compromises
there is no other option than gas
savings
unless the eu gets rid of dependency on
russian gas
the prices remain high
if we succeed
the prices will drop
proposed cuts of 15 are now voluntary
and if the target becomes mandatory the
list of opt-outs is long among the
exemptions island states not connected
to the european grid such as ireland
malta and cyprus
countries heavily dependent on gas for
electricity can also opt out necessary
flexibility ministers say to protect the
european economy as a whole
our industrial production chains are
completely interdependent if there are
problems with chemicals in germany then
the whole of european industry can stop
and that is what is at stake
it shows that europe stays united that
europe is able to find union
unity and
giving a strong signal also um in the
day where the flows of gas in nordstrom
1 are reduced and to another 20
uh to putin and to russia
you won't split us so this is the
important signal of the day
since the war in ukraine began five
months ago the need for europe to rid
itself of its dependence on russian
energy has grown by the day
governments are hoping that with winter
on the horizon supplies tightening and
prices soaring this compromise is enough
for now at brussels correspondent
christine mahuntwa explained to us how
the deal is going to work
well ben the commission says it will
provided that europe experiences what it
calls an average winter
even with all the exceptions and the
derogations as they refer to
within this deal the commission is
confident that if member states uh do
their fair share in in saving by
reducing uh gas usage and instead saving
that that we would be able to get
through the winter here in europe um of
course the the intention is to store up
reserves uh to reach a level of 80
capacity by november the reserves are
currently
at 67
the message from the commission is save
now and that will make us safer uh in
the winter that the saving has to happen
across the board and that everybody
needs to pitch in and do their fair
share now in the event that the
commission sees that there is an
emergency situation
there is a mechanism that's been baked
into this deal which would allow of
course the heads of state of the eu
member countries to trigger that
mechanism which makes this 15
uh mandatory as opposed to voluntary as
it currently is
and according to eu officials only
hungary opposed the deal
well that would be this particular deal
or the deal in this form this is about
the third draft from the commission's
initial plan that was proposed over a
week ago that really caused um havoc
that plan was rejected by a number of eu
member states it would have seen the
commission
take control over the situation in a way
be in a position to to mandate those
cuts
and dictate to to eu members how to
ration uh gas supply uh in their own
countries that was widely rejected by a
number of countries and so this version
in its current form has only been
rejected uh by hungary but bear in mind
to get here uh these concepts these
exemptions that i talked about um have
been baked in there which effectively
give a lifeline to to any eu member
state at any given time to be able to
exercise some level of exemption
so
in terms of what the eu is is showing
today it is of course something that
they can say we're united over
but in truth it was difficult getting to
this point
and anybody can tell you this is a
significantly watered-down version of
what the commission intended
christine this and the war of course are
going to isolate russia long-term but
short-term it's europeans hurting most
absolutely and uh ukraine's uh energy
minister was here as a guest today and
he's meeting and having a number of uh
sittings with the people he briefed the
media here and he said look the energy
war so as he's dubbed it begun long
before the invasion on on february 23
24th um and and what we're seeing is is
definitely that i mean prices are going
up and
j when russia reduces the in the gas
supply um that takes the prices up and
this is what's also prompted the
research that you saw by the
international agency for energy saying
that in the months of the war just the
reduction of supply has seen prices soar
to the point that russia has essentially
made three times what it would in energy
sales than it would in a given winter so
in terms of russia's capability to
continue restricting the flow of gas
well it seems to be getting incentivized
by that and of course that just means
european households will see their
energy bills rise at a time when cost of
living is already high
in the block it's going to be a
difficult winter and the commission is
hoping
that this plan will soften
what is a blow that is certain to come
from russia whether or not there will be
a total cut in that gas how long the
winter will be how severe the cold
weather will be of course these are all
unknown factors but what the commission
is saying is let's save as much as
possible it will do us better it will at
least signal to the market that there is
contingency plan but this is no doubt
going to impact uh already hard hit
european households
exactly and all we do know is that
winter is coming dw's christine
mahornbauer thank you very much for the
analysis
the social democrats parliamentary
spokesperson for energy nina shir joins
us here in germany you're calling on all
of us here to help save energy consumers
like you and me but
that's not going to be enough is it if
if there's a complete cut off
it's it's not a complete cut-off at the
moment but it's a serious situation
because 20 percent
is
if this does develop into a complete cut
off at some stage i'm asking whether or
not it's going to be enough all of us
banding together to try to reduce our
energy consumption
if it will come to cut off completely it
it will a very serious situation because
then our storages
will not be filled
at the
to the winter and then
all the european union will have a big
problem because
uh the storages um
uh are also for the
whole european union
so um 20 percent less is also
in signal we have to say okay
now it's saving the
gas is the best we can do now and it is
very necessary that we will have this
less
um using in
in gas
and
to to be able to save and to be able not
to pay for so much for gas
we have to know every every gas we will
buy for the next
weeks or month um it's very very high
priced and
this will
make
the gas consumption
in in with prices and the people who are
not picked they will not be able to pay
for so we have to save energy now very
seriously very strong
50 percent we are able to arrive um
maybe also more than 50 percent
and um
at the same time we have
also to realize
it is never absolutely necessary to
switch to renewable energy we have to
switch
more fast um we can we wanted to do
before and this is this these two things
we have to do and maybe the third thing
we yes this third thing maybe i can add
um
we have also
to be careful about um
the the people that they they will get
more help
some
people will not be able to pay for
the energy and they need more help we
gave gave them before exactly that's uh
what i wanted to ask you what is the
strategy that's in place uh by the
coalition how is the government going to
help not only consumers but companies as
well for which these gas cuts could mean
uh it could ruin their businesses and
mean layoffs
the hubs are
we helped the last month with
30
billion euro
with big packages and they
continuously
arrive the people
and
but but we we know that it is not enough
so we have to help with
money but we have also to help with um
with subsidies to to save energy and
there are also
some ideas um that can help to reduce
and um maybe also
with the i made also a proposal like
this that you're
you're getting some um
some money
back when you
were successful with saving energy and
something like this we have to do and we
have also to
to to realize that um the 15
which are now coming
um
50 percent electricity which is
coming from
gas
we have to reduce very seriously and for
this we made also some acts which were
fulfilled in the next month that more
coal power plants will
go instead of the the
gas power plant so that we we can
reduce the gas consumption of also there
and other
things we can also do for the industry
how for the industries uh that they are
able to reduce their debts
uh one thing maybe uh is also necessary
to say
with our law in the european union
the same as in in our member state
germany
the best protected
place
are the consumers
they uh the reducing of a gas
with a regulatory act is um saving the
consumers
at best okay and also
on europe's energy challenges sorry
about that we're having troubles with
the line there good to have you on the
show today
thank you
the european union's been negotiating
the agreement after moscow announced it
would slash gas deliveries through the
nordstrom 1 pipeline which runs under
the baltic sea between russia and
germany
russia claims the reduction has been due
to maintenance work and sanctions and
that a complete stoppage is not on the
cards but european officials don't
believe it and have started to prepare
for the worst
let's talk through this with methius
buck who's the director of european
energy policy at the energy transition
think tank
agora energy vendor welcome to dw um
germany's economy minister says this
deal demonstrates european solidarity
but there are a number of uh countries
who have uh opt-outs um so how much
solidarity is there
i think the political signal cannot be
overrated
it's very important that
well before
the co-period starts before heating
period starts the member states have
collectively agreed
to reduce gas demands by 15
so to be in a position to fill the
storage
of gas in europe to the level necessary
to get through the winter even
if
a situation should occur where russia
would fully cut the gas delivery cereal
so it's a very important signal it is um
putting into legislation the principle
of energy solidarity so it sends a very
strong message also to the kremlin
that this
game of dividing uh european unity
doesn't
work
you're right a number of exemptions and
derogations in
this agreement reached today
some of these exemptions are very
straightforward some of the countries in
europe are not connected physically to
the european gas grid i.e it wouldn't
really help if they are cutting
for instance malta or island they're
cutting gas
gas consumption there and it wouldn't
benefit other countries
in greater need
than those countries and then there are
some other
specific situations where countries are
particularly dependent on fossil gas for
electricity production it's those are
the baltic countries to some extent also
france at this point in time and there
are also some possibilities to then
document that uh sharing the 15 burden
is not possible right in specific
instances so
it's a good package right and we're
talking about a voluntary 15 percent cut
by winter which could be made mandatory
if surprise
reach what the eu is described as crisis
levels what do you think crisis levels
would look like in the real world
so for the um
the audience we're in a situation where
there is a big uncertainty about the
continuity of
fossil gas supplies from russia to
europe and some countries are highly
dependent so the need at this point in
time is to fill up storage levels
to
a minimum 80
before the winter and so if the
information from the countries in europe
will show
that we are not coming to this 80 at
least 80 storage
filled levels before the winter then
we're reaching a crisis situation and
then those demand reduction measures
which are at the moment voluntary will
become binding
right
well let's hear from german economy
minister robert harbeck with his
analysis of russia's evil plan if i can
put it that way and then we'll get your
take
we have seen over the past weeks and
months that russia's strategy is to keep
prices high in europe it wants to push
up the political price
in order to divide europe and drive a
wedge between it and ukraine
this decision today has sent a strong
decisive message which will also be
heard in moscow
that europe cannot be divided
what do you think is the the russian
cost-benefit analysis of cutting gas
supplies to europe that's lost revenue
against annoying the europeans
so very clearly russia is playing a
political game of seeking to divide
europe
in its unity against
russia's war of aggression against the
ukraine this is the basic setting and it
is using fossil gas supplies that it's
turning on and off as a political weapon
of course by
delivering less gas in our market-based
system prices are going up so the
relative damage from limit from
supplying less gas to the russian state
budget is relatively limited at this
point in time but of course going
forward
there is a resolve in europe in a
collective resolve to get independent
fully independent from russian fossil
fuel supplies over the next year so
there will be very significant
economic damage to russia
going forward all right and you say that
russia is attempting to divide uh europe
by by um by cutting these energy
supplies how does uh cutting uh energy
supplies to say germany through
nordstrom one um uh through the north
stream one pipeline how would that
divide europe
there is of course the north stream
pipeline specifically is highly
important for germany
if russia is selectively cutting some
gas supplies to some countries as
that has done to poland for instance to
bulgaria not to germany
um then those countries may be in need
of solidarity and then the exactly the
situation that was the the basis for
discussion today uh amongst the member
states where they reached an agreement
so if there is a country that cannot
supply itself with
fossil gas from russia or other sources
then solidarity will kick in and there
is
um under certain
conditions a mandatory sharing of um
fossil gas amongst european countries
because we do have a fairly well
connected internal european market for
gas so there is the infrastructure to to
pump up from uh to switches around the
southern europe
understood
and so
as russia loses out um on energy markets
in europe for its oil and gas is it
finding other markets
so specifically for the gas i think in
the short term there is a very clear
challenge
of course russia is currently in
cooperation with china seeking to
develop a big pipeline project from
russia to china
this will
according to what i've
read to take
three years potentially four years
and it will only be a fraction of the
fossil gas currently supplied by
pipeline to europe
um at the same time
and then the alternative lng
to liquefy the national natural gas and
to to then export it to international
markets of course it's an option but
russia is at this point in time at least
very much dependent on technologies
to
be able to to
engage in the energy market that
is not um
so it is missing some some technical
components to engage energy production
okay that's clear thank you so much for
joining us
and explaining that to us matthias buck
from the energy transition think tank
agora energy vendor
let's take a closer look at this deal
with the benjamin schmidt he's a former
european energy security advisor at the
u.s state department welcome to dw um
what's your take on this deal
well look i mean i think first phil we
have to we have to look at what's going
on uh the eu is trying to pull together
is as much as possible and this is
really an offshoot of work that's been
going on at the eu level since 2015
through the european energy union
concept this was a concept to build out
both the energy security hardware and
software meaning the diversification
infrastructure and then anti-monopoly uh
legal regulatory models uh that includes
uh third energy package uh uh gas
directive and things like this but right
now this is where the rubber really hits
the road this is where we're gonna see
if all of the energy security steps that
europe has taken over the past uh eight
or nine years are going to pay off
because this is the scenario that we've
been talking about for many years a uh
significant or even full gas cut off by
russia on the eu to limit its foreign
policy latitude to push back on russian
aggression in particular in ukraine but
in terms of you know russian hybrid
warfare elsewhere using you know
weaponization of energy space supply
chains and food so this is a really
really critical moment for the eu um to
see if that energy security preparation
is going to pay off i think it will
right now
in crude terms
i'm going to ask you a question in just
a sec but i need to set it up because
we're we're in a situation where
everybody loses from this you know
russia loses um money through uh not
supplying europe and europe of course
loses a major uh energy supplier but if
gas supplies from russia stop altogether
who suffers more do you think a
dependent europe which is heavily
dependent on russia or russia which
largely lives off its energy exports
well we're talking about a foot race
here you know the eu has more or less
said that it's going to diversify
rapidly away from dependence and in
imports of russian natural gas unlike
oil russia doesn't get as much revenue
from natural gas sales it's still
significant obviously and it should be
curtailed as much as possible to cut off
uh you know financial lines to support
uh russia's aggression in ukraine but
you uh
you can see that the the energy system
is much less fungible on the natural gas
side meaning that although there's lng
ships out there um it's not like oil and
so
cutting off natural gas to europe is in
the very shortest term um really a tool
that uh that because of lack of
diversification in countries like
germany over the past several years and
building up projects like nordstrom one
and nordstrom 2. um it's been in a
strategic vulnerability uh in terms of
you know the the situation it finds
itself in this is why putin's pulling
this lever now because in 18 months and
24 months he won't have this level as
leverage anymore hopefully understood
the supposed upside to this uh energy
crisis is that it's accelerating the
transfer to green energy
is that actually happening
i think there is but the the problem
that we have right now phil is that you
know you can't deploy uh
grid scale you know uh large-scale
renewables at um at scale to actually
push back on this immediate gas cut off
and this is why um you know ideas like
the uh econ ministry has come out with
to basically uh swap natural gas
supplies by bringing in lng from other
sources and that includes cutting off uh
you know expropriating and then cutting
off the nordstrom two pipelines and and
reconnecting them to floating storage
and re-gasification units these floating
lng terminals bring in lng from
non-russian sources
again leveraging existing infrastructure
and again when we look at these issues
you know and hopefully we'll talk
briefly about the the the siemens
turbine situation that's that's you know
central to all of this we have to have a
foreign policy that is based in
technical reality and what russia is
claiming on these turbines is completely
false we've seen statements from a
myriad of german ministries on this
front okay we'll have to leave the talk
of the siemens turbine to another day
but for now that's very clear thank you
for that ben uh benjamin schmidt is a
former european energy security advisor
to the u.s state department
thanks so much phil